Here's an example of phase one.
Both sides have
a pre-shared secret key and
they use Diffie-Hellman to establish
a new shared key, and they use
the pre-shared key to authenticate
this newly established shared key.
Here's how it works.
First the initiator sends to
the responder the crypto that
it proposes to use,
along with the cookie.
The cookie can be easily
computed by the initiator and
can be easily verified by responder.
For example,
this cookie can be computed as a hash
over the initiator's IP address and
the current time stamp together.
The cookie is used to prove that
the initiator has done some computation,
is serious about following
through the protocol.
In general, cookies are used to mitigate
denial of service attacks where
an initiator can send a lot of requests
to a responder at no, or little, cost.
The responder then sends back its
choice of crypto algorithms and
its own cookie to the initiator.
Second, here YI and
YR are the property components of the
Diffie-Hellman key exchange, and NI and
NR are the Nonce values of
the initiator and the responder.
Third, both the initiator and responder
compute the same shared key according
to Diffie-Hellman key exchange.
And other keys for the IKSA,
fourth they then exchange hash values
to authenticate the newly established
key using their pre-shared secret key.
The hash is computed
using the information
that they have just exchanged
along with the pre-shared key.
We will explain this shortly.